All right, let's get into audience questions
for the week.
First one.
Hey David.
And why is the educational divide among white
voters not there among non white voters?
This is a really good,
it may be the wrong question in a sense and
I'll explain that in a minute, but first let's
discuss what we're talking about here.
We recently did a story which looked at polling
in terms of Trump support.
And what you saw was that among black voters,
black voters basically opposed Trump by similar,
uh, in similar proportions regardless of whether
they did or didn't go to college.
Hispanic voters are opposed to Trump roughly
equally between Hispanic voters who didn't
go to college and Hispanic voters who did
et cetera within white voters, white voters
who didn't go to college are significantly
more likely to support Trump than white voters
who did go to college.
So one way to ask it is, why is there an educational
divide among white voters on supporting Republicans?
The way it may be backwards is maybe the question
is what is it about white voters where when
they aren't educated, they are falling for
Republican talking points.
But essentially we're asking the same thing
here.
Now there's a few things that aren't good
answers.
One would be it's merely about religion because
if you look at black voters, black voters
are a pretty significantly religious group.
They should be more conservative than they
are based on religiosity.
If that was sort of the X factor, it doesn't
appear to be.
When you look at Hispanic voters, education
doesn't become a dividing line I believe because
regardless of educational attainment, Hispanic
voters know that Republicans don't have their
interests in mind.
They don't propose policies that are good
for them and Hispanic voters regardless of
education aren't likely to fall for bogus
Republican talking points like the left is
really the racist party or whatever the case
may be.
The educational element becomes sort of secondary.
With a lot of these groups with white voters,
the educational differences become more of
a dividing line because nothing else is bringing
educated and uneducated voters together on
the same basis.
What I mean by that is I've explained to you
many times before, those lame Republican talking
points that don't work on Hispanic voters
regardless of education and they don't work
on black voters regardless of education because
they understand the political realities of
the Republican party.
Those talking points do work on white voters
who are not by virtue of their identity already,
uh, understanding Republican versus democratic
policy.
And because they are uneducated, they're more
likely to fall for those talking points since
there is no other sort of insulating factor
that will protect them from it.
And this becomes a self reinforcing feedback
loop where in great part, the Republican party
has written off a lot of these minority groups.
They've written off, uh, Hispanic voters and
black voters and Asian voters in many ways
because they see that their policy isn't appealing.
So they're effectively doubling down and trying
to appeal to white voters even more.
That, of course leads to a bigger divide because
the white voters who are educated have more
of a framework with which to understand and
realize that they, there are attempts to bamboozle
them, whereas the educated uneducated voters
are not.
So we have a combination here of a self reinforcing
feedback loop where in Republicans are particularly
targeting white voters and succeeding more
with those that are uneducated, combined with
the reality that in a lot of these other groups
there is something else about their place
in the political mill.
You, for lack of a better term, that reduces
the importance of what, whether they are or
are not educated.
I mean, as a very micro level, um, I know
a lot of Argentinians here in Boston, I was
born in Argentina, as many of you know.
And in the group there are drastic financial
differences where there are people who, um,
are, you know, effectively just entering the
workforce or have been in it for awhile but
earn very little money, are on social welfare
programs all the way up to medical and legal
professionals and successful entrepreneurs,
et cetera.
And across that entire group.
Nobody likes Trump.
Everybody understands the role that Trump
plays in furthering the Republican policies
that are not good for Hispanic voters.
Voters who are immigrants from Argentina,
however you wanted to find us.
Many, many Argentinians are white as the term
is, uh, and the educational level and the
class differences that exist within the group
don't really seem to move political views
one way or the other.
If you looked at an equivalent group of native
born American born white people with such
drastically different class and educational
backgrounds, my prediction is you would see
much more of a spectrum of political view.
So those are some of my ideas.
Let me know what I'm missing.
Um, very important question and an important
one to understand, uh, when looking at the
20, 20 election for sure.